oh my gosh sean sean
oh man
i don't know i don't even know who i am
right now
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm sean evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by kevin james
he's an actor his career in comedy
touches everything from stand up to
massively successful tv shows and films
check out the kevin james youtube
channel as we quickly approach 1 million
subscribers
and his latest project is the crew a
comedy series set to release on netflix
february 15th
kevin james welcome to the show thanks
for having me sean
i appreciate it i am uh i'm ready i'm
i'm a little nervous i'm not
i'm not going to lie because if anybody
was built to succeed
on this show you would think i i would i
would be
it you know and and i am just a certain
point and then i'm not i'm worried about
the wheels coming off but
we're going to get through it together
[Music]
i'm going to glove up do you mind if i
do a uh
on one side just because i've gotten the
stuff in the eye no i think that's very
smart
prescient okay
all right here we go this is now what
this one
yup the classic classic that looks sweet
it looks innocent
red
[Music]
okay yeah
[Music]
that's a nice taste yeah that's good so
i want to start by talking
about your series the crew which is set
in a nascar garage and focused on the
characters who work the pit
and i've seen you grand marshaling race
events since as far back as 2007.
has any of that boots on the track
experience help to inform this new role
that you have as a nascar crew chief
it did it's insane if you've never been
to one of these events i had no idea
what goes on there it's
it's crazy i mean the whole tailgate
party situation
is on the inside it's on the inside the
infield of the track
they got the the racing going on the pit
crew the teams are going the military's
there
the crowds are going nuts it's an insane
event
and i become a fan and i'm trying to
learn more and more about it ever since
[Music]
all right here we go do i keep the lips
out of it do you try to do that is there
something
to that or no well i've seen everybody
try
everything but it's it's like that mike
tyson quote about
everyone having a plan until you get
punched in the mouth i would say
try to keep the lips off as long as you
can but eventually
it's just a free-for-all yeah yeah i
like this one
it's got a nice pepperoncini taste
so i want to compliment you on your
youtube channel which has been on fire
during quarantine with a mix of short
films and sketches that
have all the production quality of a
major motion picture
and you know often times when
celebrities go onto youtube
they do youtube things but you with
every upload you've stayed committed to
this storytelling
looking back on now what is close to a
year-long foray
what have you gotten out of the kevin
james youtube experience
you know what i gotta be honest i gotta
give credit to uh this uh family of
brothers
there's like eight of them uh the
canaans that uh
they're insanely talented family of
directors
editors they do everything they kept
saying let's just do shorts and quick
little movies and
i mean i fell in love with it it's an
amazing experience to do it it was
cathartic for me
and you know you're putting something
hopefully funny out in the world there
and they're amazing they were it was
great
it's really one of the few avenues where
you can do whatever you want and there's
nobody telling you
what to put in what to put out you got
to do this it's for kids
for this with that we got to add this
and so
i was sold i was like i enjoyed doing
that so much you know
i enjoy movies too you know but it's
like there's so much more pressure with
that this we were just out having fun
that was it
okay that wasn't good touched with this
hand already not a smart move
i got no heat yet nothing do you
yeah well listen i'm like a lab
experiment over here you know
um really good taste really good so i
think that it's safe to say that
wait i spoke too soon
yeah just a tinge it just
it just knocked on my tongue and what
did you say about me
thank you bud so i think that it's safe
to say that as a food lover you
represent the people's palate you'd be
much more comfortable with a lineup of
burgers in front of you from an
all-american drive-through than you
would be with
a 20-course tasting menu at a five-star
restaurant so what i want to do is hit
you with a few
food headlines that have popped up in
the news lately and i'm just curious
how you react to them is the people's
gourmand
first one this is this week from eater
billionaires row condo requires its
residents to spend
fifteen thousand dollars a year at
private restaurant
that's crazy i i i i am not
i would not like that i would not live
there i would not do that because
you're trapped with that type of food
like down and dirty
is better for me from a diner to a
mom-and-pop little crappy sandwich shop
on the side of a highway if it's good
it's good
you know i i can eat the higher end
stuff but i don't prefer it
this is from nbc connecticut connecticut
lawmakers propose making
pizza the official state food and this
seemed to incense the rest of the
tri-state area
yeah connecticut's you know what i think
they have a few places
i don't want to name names and i think
they think they're in the game
uh with new york and jersey it's just to
me
i don't know i think they should stick
with you know what they got the original
hamburger up there i think in
connecticut
i think that's what they've made be
happy with that stay with that unless
you prove me different long island
is pretty badass for pizza this is from
the new york post
vegan bodega now serving meatless takes
on classic new york city sandwiches
the place is called the vodega and it
serves options like
a jackfruit cuban and a seitan philly
cheese steak for around 14 bucks
no no no just no no
no no no that's like no
in a philly cheesesteak and you're gonna
do it vegan it doesn't work just stay in
your lane
that's fine say you can't eat meat and
you don't want to
go ahead but i'm letting you know i'm
eating double to make up for what you're
not eating i will eat
this isn't a headline but i think i
should bring it to your attention that
there are
internet lists of the greatest breakfast
sandwiches in the country
that do not include a single bacon egg
and cheese from long island
does that invalidate all rankings in
your opinion
it absolutely does you can't say
something else when you
when you degrade a a breakfast sandwich
from long island
a deli anything else you say is there's
no there is no truth
[Music]
okay got on the lips already i like this
one
it's good a little more of a kick for
sure yeah
nice so in addition to playing a teacher
turned fighter and here comes the boom i
know that you've been a day one ufc
fan sitting ringside at events way
before that was a cool thing for
celebrities to do
can you give us one hollywood trade
secret when it comes to the art of the
fight scene it's
clear from watching your work that you
have a deep appreciation for the craft
oh i love it and it was funny because i
got in shape from the boom
but i wasn't in the greatest shape still
like i wasn't completely fit and i
should have gotten better shape
you know and i realized that when we
were shooting because i was getting so
gassed and a lot of these uh fighters
that i was
fighting with they don't know they've
never act
fought before like a couple times i go
hey hey hey whoa
where we're at here these guys don't
have that speed once they're in the
fight and they're kind of throwing
energy
they're not gonna throw their punch to
the right they're gonna you know they're
trained to hit you in the chin
and i got wobbled a couple times but uh
it's fun it was it was i'm glad i got to
do it from that
angle too it's a nice way to almost get
props for fighting without fighting
and then my favorite kevin james fun
fact is that you're on the same high
school wrestling team as wwe hall of
famer mick foley
could you see his wrestling potential
back then when you guys were teenagers
no you know i was uh i played football i
was a running back on the team
and i never wrestled really before but
uh they needed a heavyweight and another
heavyweight to go with mick
uh so they brought me over and we used
to have some battles i would
kind of throw him around a little bit i
was i think i was in better shape than
him back then
but he started that's where the the
demented mind was developing i remember
him jumping off his roof into like
cardboard boxes and
he was just doing these weird things and
he's the nicest guy ever i mean he's
incredible
writes children's books and he's the
sweet does more for charity he's just a
great
great guy but he's a little off he's
definitely a little off jimmy fallon
once described
you as great at falling how if at all
has your background in sports and mixed
martial arts
influenced you as a physical comedian i
love being physical
i love physical comedians big ones
especially i mean you know jackie
gleason to me is is the greatest of all
time and he was a big guy who could
dance and move and i love that
you know so i love the physicality of
not only comedy of just acting and
moving and
action movies and you know so it's it's
always been in there and i've always you
know i always try to bring it and it's
get it gets harder as you get older but
uh
it's still there
[Music]
can i say something i got a little
residual from the last one
this is yours yeah this is you make this
one
but you know what kevin if you don't if
you don't like it don't don't lie to me
don't lie
trust me trust me
one thing i'm not shy that's fantastic
i mean that high compliment all right
kevin james we have a recurring segment
on our show called explain that gram
where we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context
so i'll show you the picture you tell us
the bigger story
first things first how big a deal was it
for you to meet
joe namath and then how do you cope do
you have a hack for coping as a jets fan
yeah um it's just i mean i'm so used to
it now it's like you with the wing sauce
it's like how do you how are you doing
that you know and everybody says that
how do
you deal with the jet sucking it's like
i've been doing it since i was you know
forever joe named was awesome it was
awesome i was at a jet game and uh
got to meet him i had met him once
earlier when i was
literally i think four years old and he
was at
the uh smithhaven mall in a fur coat and
you know it was the day heyday of
broadway joe
and i got to meet him then and he was
very cool both times so that was a dream
come true that was very cool
i think that you have used your fame to
get into more
sort of like fantasy camp exhibitions
than anybody else i can think of off the
top of my head
when you think back on all the celebrity
softball
and soccer and golf and tennis and
nascar and i could go on and on and on
do you have a single sort of crowning
athletic achievement
yes it was uh beating tiger woods
at a uh at a a short mini golf
tournament we had
for uh way back in the day when he had a
charity event he's competitive he lost
to me
i beat him at golf and it was amazing i
like to leave out the fact that he was
only allowed three clubs
that was his he so he chose a driver
i think a five iron uh
and a i think a wedge and and he
used he putted with his driver but i
beat him i drained a putt i think and
uh tiger he was a little off on it but
he was cool
i'm taking that with me charles barkley
was there they all know
they know who won it
[Music]
tears of the sun private reserve is this
the private reserve
i don't want the or if it's just the
regular reserve i'm not going to do it
only the finest top shelf for kevin
james private reserve
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
this is the first one where the heat
came in with like the taste
taste was getting in and it was like he
was like hey what's up i'm here too it's
like i'm i'm what
they kind of hit at the same time a wave
a real wave of heat with this one
they didn't wait he didn't wait in the
parking lot and say i'll bring you in
later he's in there now
that's good though that's a good one so
i've heard you say that you try to
connect with the everyday
every guy and a lot of your most iconic
characters reflect that salt of the
earth sensibility
you'll often hear politicians or
marketers talk about the everyman with
at least a
professed reverence while cultural
critics it's almost
used as a disparaging term do you
clock that how do you think about that
duality
i forget someone said it but like uh
there's a reason you watch
uh james bond you know uh when he does a
uh a movie like
because it's something you would never
do and it's it's exciting and you lose a
life that you don't have
that's not why people watch me people
watch me because i would do that
exact thing that that guy would do
hopefully you know like that's what you
want to do
get connecting with with the you know
husbands and wives where they're just
like
we are just like you and you know your
wife in the show or this or that
it's tough for a career too because
every time you do a movie especially if
you do one that works out well
half the audience wants you to do that
again they're comfortable with that
character so they want to see that again
so they're like put something out like
that again and then you do that and then
you lose
half your uh your audience where they're
like well we already saw that you know
what else you got you know
so it's like and if you do something
different they're not as thrilled
so it's it's that constant battle of
trying to please and and
ultimately i just try to throw the
widest net possible
and catch you know as many people as i
can but you can't you got to be
who you are and that's why again the
youtube channel for me is just
just do what i think is funny and that's
it have fun don't worry about it let
everybody else catch up
[Music]
i see a woman she's got the glasses and
a sword
[Music]
okay
yeah yep hello
i'm just talking talking
yeah that hit now all right
wow okay yeah let's play
let's play you know what that's that's a
good one
okay all right so kevin james i wasn't
aware of this but
hitch is a big hit with the hot ones
crew the 2005
highly quotable highly rewatchable film
that to date is still the third highest
grossing rom-com of all time
in that iconic dance scene with will
smith where you're making a pizza and
tossing out a q-tip
you can almost see will holding back a
smile how much of that scene was
improvised
a lot was we were going back and forth
we were just working throwing up things
back and forth trying different things
and he said you have anything
and i go you know what i don't know what
i have so i would just start thinking of
items around me things in my bathroom
whatever it was and
that's where you know make the pizza and
the q-tip and all that stuff
just being stupid i had no idea we shot
a bunch of stuff
the will was cracking up i'm like if i'm
making will laugh
you know that's all i got to do right
now and uh i was so happy
how it came out wow you guys have really
designed it well that way right you know
it's just a
you know that feeling when you're taking
off and you just go right above the
clouds you got a little
and then you're just up yeah what
okay
you got me worried now
wow wow
that is that is that's so
[Music]
so bad by the way
that tastes like frozen dog poop with
hot sauce on it like that is
literally there's no joy to that
oh my gosh sean sean oh man
i don't know i don't even know who i am
right now
that changed everything yeah we'll never
be the same kevin we'll never be the
same
i know i will be sean i love you but
right now i want to put your face in a
bag and punch it
i just want to for my money your most
underrated project is making the cut the
road to pebble beach
which followed you and ray romano on
your quest and the days leading up to
the pro-am
is there a shot or moment that still
haunts you to this day when you think
about
missing the cut by only two strokes yeah
on 17 i remember i remember
oh my gosh i think it was 17 or no
maybe 18. i think i went in the drink i
forget where it was
i remember i went in the drink a couple
times uh so pissed off but you know what
ray went on he didn't make the cut did
he he missed it by one stroke he missed
him
he was drunk he missed it chris berman
swung that putt
yeah so this goes insanity so it goes up
to insanity
and then it says that's not good enough
beyond it
that's a nasty little fat bottle [ __ ]
right there look at that
cheers bud sure
okay that doesn't feel as bad as the
bomb
is it coming ultimately
if you take on the bomb i feel like it
almost scorches the earth in your mouth
yeah yes the bomb crushes everything so
now there's no feeling there's no love
there's no
hate there's nothing we're playing with
house money kevin we're playing with
house money
we did it so far right
can i go for another one
[Music]
all right come here salute yeah i like
that one
so i want to open this wing with a
little story about bill gates who
credits his early success with the fact
that he grew up next door to the
university of washington
where he had access to some of the best
state-of-the-art computer labs in the
world
does anything about that little bill
gates story resonate with you
when you think about coming up in that
prolific
long island comedy scene in minnevini's
east side comedy club
that was back in the day it was
absolutely a product it's where i
started richie marvini was the greatest
because
it's a stand-up you uh when you're first
starting out
and even to this day you know i think
the most important thing is stage time
is getting up on stage
trying to find who you are not your
jokes will change and everything will
change but just finding a persona
that you know you can you know roll with
richie minovini was the best because he
would just give you time to just say
just go and just do it and you would
suck he'd say but suck stay up there
and you you know you build up a presence
you know and you learn
to be comfortable in the uncomfortable
which is
uh you know a really good tool to have
it stand up is my mouth
filling up with water so it's like
having guys like you know eddie murphy
and all these
amazing stand-ups come in and out of
there it was always the best place to
grow up for me for
up you know that is a legendary stage
that helped launch the careers of people
like
eddie murphy or jim carrey or uh
ray romano when you first started who
was like
kevin james's comedian's comedian i mean
i loved robert klein robert klein was
always the one you know
he just he was the one i saw his hbo
special that
just floored me and i loved his style of
comedy
i mean richard lewis was funny too he
was great you know you take on
these guys and you love them and you try
to mimic your act then you find your own
voice but through them those are the
ones that really inspired me
to become a comedian
by the way we did all this with no drink
yeah no reflexive drinking until we roll
credits kevin
okay what do i do with this just a
little extra on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to
[Music]
ooh ceremonial that's a lot that went in
there
that's good fireworks show to close
things out
cheers cheers kevin thank you for
getting me through this
so far
[Music]
but going back in kevin james man of the
people
[Music]
kevin here we are at the closing credits
of our spicy wing journey together
we've talked about your films your new
show the plight of being a jets fan
but i want to close with your abiding
deep love for pizza
you've compared the pie scene in long
island to heaven and one of the most
circulated kevin james quotes is
there's no better feeling in the world
than a warm pizza box on your lap
what makes long island pizza better than
all other pizza
and don't say the water it's the
standard of which i know pizza
long island pizza it's even different
than the city just got hot
but it got hot but uh there's just a
different there's just a feeling that i
knew i grew up with that's
it it's long island pizza and it's
basically in every strip mall
every strip mall on long island you'll
get a good one
and a decent one anyway but this that's
that's it that's the market for me i've
been to italy tried everywhere
i keep coming back long island grandma's
slice or sicilian
you know what that's like telling you
which which one of your kids do you like
better you know so it's like
um always good i love the grandma slice
but i'm a sicilian guy but i'm also
classic always
oh yeah yeah i'm good
and then finally which of the hot sauces
that you've tried today do you think
would pair
best with a next day reheat slice
this is the one the apollo i like it the
most honestly i really do because
it's got the heat i like the heat but
you can blend it and you can kind of
you put i would also put it in a sundae
sauce
high compliments for apollo we'll take
that kevin james and look at you my man
taking on the sauce the king of queens
and the king of hot sauce now there's
nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you
kevin james this camera that camera
probably just the one you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on all right i'm all over the place here
we are
netflix the crew check it out february
15th
man this was unbelievable sean i'm a
huge fan of yours
i thank you for interviewing me and
talking me through this i felt safe the
whole way
like a like a baby in a mother's arms
okay that was awesome
thank you and no drink by the way
nothing and i'm not gonna get one
and i'll go in for more i'm gonna go in
for more
you're really good thank you that's the
one
standing ovation from steven and camera
guy bill in the studio
hot ones truth or dab the game the kit
comes complete with 250 question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice
just like in the show answer it honestly
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
take
a look at this there's even a mini
bottle of the last dab
included i suggest you have napkins on
hand you have to have some milk on hand
and of course be careful be very careful
around the eyes hot ones truth or dab
the play at home
game is available at shop.firstwe
fees.compeatness.com and
amazon play at your own risk wings
not included